the reviews are in Daily wire has
arguably the biggest movie in America
right now 97% score on Rotten Tomatoes
that's an audience score critics don't
want to talk about it let's get to a
video take it away I um yeah you know it
it is funny when you remember that a
significant portion of far-right
grifters used to be in entertainment
like they wanted to make it in Hollywood
or comedy uh uh Crowder uh Ben Shapiro
uh like a lot of them you know um NS
like theater kids you know okay excuse
me put a pause there listen it's true I
was the lead in all the plays I was also
as class president buddies with the
hockey team I did some other stuff you
do all these different things but you do
one Play You're a theater
kid all right go on Mr vou producers is
that who this is Bou okay keep going so
a while back the daily wire committed a
very large amount of money to the
project of producing anti-woke media to
be a parallel Hollywood now I ask you
guys have you seen literally
any broader cultural impact to the kind
of stuff they've been producing this is
not their first movie going to guess no
the reason for that of course is because
uh conservatives uh fascists in
particular just aren't that good at
making art okay put a pause here first
of all
our early movies uh did pretty well but
this is actually the first dailywire
movie that we made with an in-house
script in-house Talent in-house
everything and we made it in like six
months so it is different than the other
movies keep going they don't have they
they're not interested in making art
they're attempting to make political
propaganda but they're not queuing the
artists in on that you know you can make
Artful propaganda but it's hard and
they're not here for it that's why they
aren't working in Hollywood the place
they would have rather been uh than
where they are now so the cultural
impact here barely minimal I feel
besides this being funny and I do find
it funny hey there you go that's pretty
funny okay not not bad it actually was
relatively flattering a lot of them say
you know these guys they just they got
into politics because they flunked out
of Hollywood or something which it's
true a lot of us did work in Hollywood
to some degree though in my case as an
adult I worked professionally in
politics before I worked ever in any
movies or anything like that so uh you
know it's kind of a
return
I think he seemed to sort of like the
movie didn't he like he obviously had to
criticize it all the time but it's it's
he said it was kind of
funny not bad let me say this
okay if this wasn't a daily wire movie
this doesn't this is actually good
material to make a movie about it remind
it's like a up version of like white
chicks or something right like there is
material here that could actually be
like a good movie if it just wasn't the
if it wasn't the daily wire cuz you know
it's going to be cringe but excuse me oh
Mr muon how did he get in this movie
wait what is that why he's been taking
so many streaming breaks are these seats
open never mind the daily wire has a
good ass business plan they do all their
so well pretty good I don't mind that at
all I haven't heard much of a review
here from any of these people other than
you know I hate the daily
wire daily wire they're super cringe I
hate them they're really bad but none of
them seem to be really engaging with the
movie itself in as much as they do they
say that's actually pretty it's pretty
funny premise that's pretty good
material not bad you know I've got a
holiday gift idea that is sure to make
you the hero of the Season we all know
that Christmas time can be a little
hectic the shopping the cooking the
never ending list of things to do but if
Fe not this gift is not just thoughtful
it's downright transformative it is the
gift of genus cell skincare from now
until Christmas genus cell's most
popular package as a special discount
for our listeners jus.com nsyt letter y
letter T treat yourself and your loved
ones to the the absolute best skincare
in the world those troubling forehead
wrinkles Fine Lines skin redness and yes
even a sagging jawline will disappear
right before your eyes with jus cell's
most popular collection Jus cell
promises immediate effects you'll see
results in less than 12 hours guaranteed
to we your money back Jus cell made
Christmas come early this year they sent
down a ton of products for everyone at
our office everyone is raving about them
and everyone's way hotter now I really
love jus cell a Coptic Christian from
Egypt founded it came over here for the
American dream their products are
absolutely top-notch I think they lose
money actually on the first orders cuz
they give these incredible deals but
they know that you're going to keep
coming back cuz the product is so good
jys cell.com nsyt get this great
Christmas discount every order instantly
upgraded to free express shipping genu
cell.com
nsyt today we watched it live last night
wow nice suit Zipit Stanley I mean I'm
not joking the the most cringe
inducing piece of film I have ever had
to endure All Those Years playing
basketball well I never really felt like
myself decade in Hollywood trying to
figure out who I really was and then I
started working at the dollhouse
and this is the Romy coach like you
would you would think a movie that is
mocking the
lgbtq movie was a good scene would be
funny notice what he does he's pulling
out this scene that's a major turn in
the movie and he's saying well it's
supposed to be why aren't you being
funny why aren't you making me laugh
because they're making a deadly point
the character they start out it's just a
big joke and this character starts to
question his gender because that's
really what happens because this is a
social contagion this is why there were
like three people who thought that they
were transgender 5 minutes ago and now
it's a huge proportion of gen Z yeah
that's true that scene there there's a
funny punch line to that scene but that
scene is deadly serious and this guy's
got no way to refute it so he says well
that's supposed to be funny no no man
that one's that one's pretty serious
like you had one job you had one
job you couldn't do that no there's
multiple jobs put a pause the movie is
supposed to be funny and it is very
funny and the reviews the audience
reviews say that it's very funny that's
not the only job of the movie the other
job of the movie is to hold a mirror up
to reality and that's what the movie
does the movie holds up a a mirror to
reality and it's it's absurd that's why
it's funny the in congruity is just
built in between the fantasy that the
libs are pushing and reality but there's
something really dark about that
absurdity and people get hurt as a
result of it that's another big job for
the movie this
movie gave me brain rot it was an SNL
skit without the skit without the the
punch line it's why is he wearing this
mask insulting and like literally
offensive to watch I'm actually upset he
is upset and I'm sure he was offended
because he was
triggered I um I have some unfortunate
news I am not a lady baller I had my
lady balls remove and I don't know where
they went but if you want to help me
find them you type exclamation point
charity and donate to the link and I
will um your support will help me with
the search and rescue mission hold on
can we put a pause right there does that
comment me I can't tell if that's just
cuz this is kind of a Lial case and I
don't want to insult an actual
Woman by suggesting she's really a
man well let's just keep going you can
tell already from like the level of
these jokes that the demographic they're
making this for is for the demographic
that grew up in a room that was
insulated with asbest and lined with
Leed paint this is literally like if
they decided to do a remake of um Freaky
Friday except worse somehow like at
least Freaky Friday was original this is
so bad put a pause here
is this person lecturing us on Comedy
I'm not saying we're some nor McDonald's
over here but these are not exactly uh a
no Henny Youngman okay the on liners are
not Landing for me keep going it's like
it's just a ripoff of a bunch of
different movies there's no creativity
behind it it's like not even offensive
you know I just I feel like I just uh I
feel
like I feel worse now in in every sense
of the word worse I am cringing on a
physical on a mental on a spirit put a
pause there this person is not cringing
on a physical level I know that because
I'm watching him I'm going to go with
him if I'm being rude to a woman who you
know is just unfortunate then I'm
sorry that's not a cringe that's a kind
of I'm looking at like a more of a
pucker face and otherwise just a normal
face so it might be a spiritual or
otherwise metaphysical cringe but it's
not a physical one all right thank you
to Mr M's Destiny and vou and who anyway
thank you to all of them for the reviews
keep them coming so that we can keep uh
the box office coming in on what might
possibly be the biggest comedy of the
year